New York Times op-ed section and author
of the new book how to fight
anti-semitism Barry Weiss is back with
us
[Music]
it's great to see you only got your
cards you're all ready to go good
nervous I know well let's talk about
your book you must know your book pretty
well you just wrote it yeah well I
thought yeah of course it is very
serious but I thought the interesting
many interesting parts of it but
something I would like to hear you talk
about is the fact that anti-semitism
it's more than just about the Jews
it's about the health of a society that
for pretty much all through human
history has certainly as long as the
Jews have been around whenever a society
becomes anti-semitic it's an indication
about something wrong in their body
politic that's interesting to me that's
exactly right I wrote this book not just
because my synagogue in Pittsburgh was
the one that was shot up in October 27
2018 but because the more I researched
this topic and looked at Jewish history
and really all of history I found that
societies were anti-semitism thrives or
societies that are dead or dying why is
that it's because anti-semitism is the
ultimate conspiracy and when
anti-semitism thrives it's a it's a sign
that that society has replaced truth
with lies and so anti-semitism is a kind
of the one way to think about it is that
it's a thought virus that's carried
forward in civilization and just like
any of us have lots of viruses in our
body at a given time for as long as
we're healthy they don't show themselves
when a society begins to become
unhealthy and tearing itself apart as we
see here and throughout Europe
anti-semitism begins to show its face
but why did why the Jews why do they
have the kick me sign on their back well
I mean but I'd have to go back to the
book of Matthew and even before that to
Egypt in 300 BCE the the there's so many
different peoples in the world sure I
mean I mean a lot of them have gotten
[ __ ] from a lot of people just seems the
Jews are always on the move
yeah we are we are here's one reason for
it so when the Jews rejected Jesus is
the Son of God oh that thing okay
[Applause]
so if you look at it you're right the
ideas get the the most I need ooze get
the most powerful empire in the world
the Roman Empire to do their bidding by
killing Jesus and if you look at the
anti-semitic tropes that we see now what
is the Jew the Jew is not it's not like
racism where the person of color is
subhuman and the ant and the racist is
merging down in the anti-semitic
conspiracy theory the Jew is the wily
manipulator the puppeteer the person
close to power that gets power to do its
bidding
and away it all goes back to that
original conspiracy well I am no expert
on Judaism although I try never to pay
retail
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Oh like this we could be different but
yeah you may also make the point that
they're kind of getting at the Jews are
from both sides I mean it was always the
right the fascist they always had a
thing out for the Jews but you know in
the last twenty thirty years it's also
been the left and I mean you talk about
how being anti-semitic now is survivable
American politics
well it's certainly survivable
survivable in European politics I mean
just at the Labor Party which is run by
an anti-semite Jeremy Courtwright who's
transformed you know one of the most
important political parties and is in
Wonju he's not great look what's
happening I mean my fear is that that
sort of thing could be happening in the
Democratic Party and I see that in you
know the the the squad that you and
Michael we're talking about before where
unfortunately some members of the squad
support the BDS movement against Israel
which seeks nothing less than the
elimination of any Jewish state between
the Jordan River and the Mediterranean
Sea I mean I'm sure people are gonna say
hey you're all talking about this when
just this week Bibi Netanyahu was
talking about annexing parts of the West
Bank which I'm not sure if I think
that's a great idea but you know they
have had 70 years to do something to
come up with a peace deal if if there
wasn't this this incessant hostility yes
it's a terrible situation both sides
have a claim to the land the Jews
seventy years ago were like let's share
it right they were like no we want to
kill all of you so when you when you
demand all and you don't get it make a
deal it could be also the left is
insisting because it benefits their
worldview the brother left on conflating
what I think of as Bibi ISM with Zionism
these are two very distinctive things I
am a huge critic of the current prime
minister of the State of Israel I
believe that just as the Jews have a
claim to the land so to to the
Palestinians and if Israel wants to be a
democratic liberal state
the idea it's like but but those people
are trying to say that just because
bee-bees Prime Minister that says how
Israel doesn't have a right to exist you
would never make that argument that just
because we have a terrible president
right now we should just man till
America let's not forget that first of
all ninety-seven percent of the West
Bank was on the table in the 90s in the
Oslo Accords they did not take that deal
also the West Bank was controlled by
Jordan for 19 years
where was the Palestinian state then
these are things you don't hear in the
American media okay let me ask you oh
now we have five years so let me ask you
about this it you read something
interesting about how we used to be
afraid and this is personal to me kiss
the anniversary of 9/11 I always think
about the tragic events of 917 when I
what that was the six days after I went
on yeah and I get fired after that and
you know I got canceled because we're
canceled before canceling before it was
a thing when it happened literally in TV
and it was because the sponsors pulled
out and you say now it's not really the
advertisers
it's the readers it is because because
of social media I believe that if all of
the journalists who worked for the New
York Times and frankly every other paper
in this country it's your paper yep got
off Twitter for six months we would see
a wildly different and an improved way
of covering the news and the reason for
that is that Twitter its and by the way
it's not just journalists it's
politicians I was talking to because I
was talking to the chief of staff of a
popular congresswoman and he was talking
about how all of the staffs of all of
these politicians literally just look at
Twitter look at the reaction and then
calibrate what the politicians gonna say
based on that immediate response and the
same thing I think is happening in
journalism which is that we're looking
to what enrages readers and frankly if
you're a normal human being you don't
want to step into a minefield I mean
with you know exceptions we all have but
yeah I mean that is the problem is that
because we have just this immediate
reader response I fear that it's sort of
corrupting with the work the answer is
that P
should be able to step into the
minefield of course earless Lee because
unless we stand up to Twitter and that
mob nothing is gonna change and Trump is
gonna get reelected because he makes
Twitter his [ __ ] and Twitter makes
Democrats their [ __ ]
you